[Musik]
der äußerste osten finnlands wälder und
seen nur 30 kilometer bis zur russischen
grenze
zwischen dezember 1939 und januar 1940
ereignete sich in diesen wäldern
weltgeschichte der winterkrieg eine
handvoll finnen auf skiern stoppte eine
sowjetische invasion
die schlacht von sony ist eine
heldengeschichte die jeder finde kennt
[Musik]
das rad den port die museum erzählt
diese geschichte im kleinen
befinden uns hier an der berühmten
straße von rate wo die 44 der
sowjetische division zerstört wurde
wer den ort der heldentat besuchen
möchte sollte zeit mitbringen denn der
weg ist weit
[Musik]
von helsinki aus sind es mit dem auto
siebeneinhalb stunden
nationalen pausen nicht mitgerechnet
[Musik]
genau hier griffen im winter 1939 zwei
sowjetische divisionen an deren panzer
blieben in den verschneiten wäldern
stecken und die weit unterlegenen finnen
machten kurzen prozess sie stoppten die
kolonnen und nahmen sich die panzer
einzeln vor die finnische motti taktik
wird bis heute an militärakademien
geleert und die ukraine sind gelehrige
schüler
in der sowjetunion war es verboten über
den winter krieg zu sprechen in finnland
ist er ein nationalepos und die finnen
sagen nichts hat sich seitdem geändert
[Musik]
es gibt so viele gemeinsamkeiten mit dem
krieg in der ukraine
die propaganda die den angriff der roten
armee auf finnland begleitete ist nahezu
dieselbe die dem angriff der russen auf
die ukraine vorausgehen
in drei tagen sei der krieg gewonnen
sagten die sowjetische offiziere
doch dieser straße führte ins verderben
überall am wegesrand findet sich noch
heute kriegs schrott fässer
munitionskisten kochgeschirr
finnland wurde zum friedhof der roten
armee
[Musik]
ein massengrab
79 soldaten der sowjetunion
hier ist das grab
am ende der schlacht waren mehr als
12.000 sowjetische soldaten verwundet
erfroren oder tod die meisten von ihnen
stammten aus der ukraine
ausgerechnet
die polit rux das waren die politischen
kommissare der roten armee
sie sagten den soldaten dass in finnland
warenhäuser und essen auf dem tisch auf
sie warten würden dass man sie mit
offenen armen empfangen würde genau
dasselbe was man den russischen soldaten
vor dem einmarsch in die ukraine
erzählte
moskaus außenminister molotow begründete
dem krieg 1939 mit angeblichen
sicherheitsinteressen außerdem wolle man
quasi en passant die finnen vom joch des
kapitalismus befreien genau wie die
ukraine war auch finnland 1917
unabhängig vom russischen zarenreich
geworden
all das
hat man in helsinki nie vergessen jedes
größere gebäude verfügt hier über einen
bunker dieser bietet sogar sportplätze
und einen spielplatz man soll sich im
krieg langweilen
der winter krieg in finnland ist er
national mythos und national trauma
zugleich
und dieses buch kennt hier fast jeder
wir sollten vorsichtig über dem rand um
zu sehen was der russe und der frieden
verstand es war so still dass mir die
ohren weh taten auch die russen späten
zu uns herüber bis zu deren stimmungen
waren es 55 50 metern einige russen
standen auf und punkten und feierte mit
den armen traute sie aber nicht ganz aus
ihren schutz grebe herauszukommen und
wir werden es auch nicht
die verfilmung von winterkrieg ist einer
der erfolgreichsten finnischen filme
aller zeiten in deutschland kam er nur
ins heimkino russen als aggressoren das
wollte niemand sehen die filme seien das
schon immer anders
die finnen haben kannst doch auch nach
dem krieg gedacht dass wir wenn wir mit
mit russen handelt denn und und alles in
ordnung ging die fracht in den ganzen
zeit dass das man muss vorsichtig durch
sein und schon in zwanziger und
dreißiger trainierte man frei
freiwillige
golfs für krieg und finden sehr großer
freiwilliger arme also 39 endlich
anfangen es war
400.000 mann und die schätze in die
freiheit zu hoffen dass jetzt sieht man
dass die jungen leute die sagen ja wir
wollen
bei den friedensverhandlungen im märz
1940 mussten die freiheitsliebenden
finnen dennoch große teile karelien sun
die sowjetunion abtreten
400.000 menschen flohen der grundstein
des nächsten krieges den finnland
deutlich verlor
unterwegs an die russische grenze wie
die mehrheit der finnen befürwortet auch
rhema den nato-beitritt die leute auf
der anderen seite der grenze seien nicht
schlecht sagt er aber denen in moskau
traue er nicht auch damit ist er hier
nicht alleine